alors maruschka detmers journée où tu
vas finir film d idy et on a commencé à
l'autre déjà oui on a fini de tourner
d
avec départ de toulouse
il ya deux semaines à peu près ya trois
semaines
dans trois jours je vais commencer à
notre film surprise surprise si vite
après l'autre un film de daniel vigne
qui s'appelle comédie d'été ou très très
très très jolie street puis si ça a pu
alors apparemment connaissions ginette
film de menem golan qui sort alors c'est
la guerre d'années en france et à
nassour vous êtes connu comment avec
madame johanne parce que c'est pas en
fait au départ c'est plutôt un
producteur réalisateur c'est quelqu'un
que monter quand même groupe qui est un
truc énorme
vous êtes rencontrés comment moi aussi
je croyais qu'il officiellement
collecteur mais en fait il m'a raconté
qu'il avait mise en scène
beaucoup de filles plutôt des films
d'action et
ramage vaut elle donc
d'action c'est pas faut pas croire c'est
ainsi des gains même une partie bon oeil
c'est vrai qu'il a fait delta force et
l'opération ensemble dans pop puis un
truc avec stallone c'est vrai qu'au
début ça fait penser à ça et puis d'un
seul film bascule complètement parce
qu'il faut dire ce que c'est quoi c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune d'une jeune fille
juive en hongrie qui vivent en israël
une histoire vraie
oui c'est la jeanne d'arc israélienne à
masséna oui on aime bien des messages
comme ça ma vie en france alors
apathique de choses
toi tu n'es pas juive est ce que tu
penses c'était difficile pour toi de tes
assimilé à ce personnage qui est
pareillement un peu finalement le modèle
quoi pour les poulets pour les juifs
européens de cette époque et puis pour
ceux qui ont survécu
est-ce que ça a été difficile de rentrer
dans ce personnage avant que toi tu
vénères hollande après la guerre non
médical a été marquée spécialement par
ça le film a été très difficile à
tourner c'est sûr mais pas pour cette
raison là plutôt parce que l'émotion
d'être intense à chaque instant mais ça
m'a pas gêné de ne pas être juive parce
que justement elle est devenue un
symbole
je vais proposer quelque chose je peux
avoir le chapeau justement n'est-ce pas
là chapeau bleu
ce que c'est
[Musique]
tiens une question question au hasard
clermont reste un jeu sans les la
question
je rapprocherais tue la création d'un
état palestinien en cisjordanie les
territoires occupés moi je ne sais pas
c'est un problème insoluble si c'était
pas si c'était un problème celui beurel
résolue depuis longtemps parce que je
crois qu'on trouvera jamais une solution
difficile je vois c'est difficile avant
l'été car hier nathalie simpson chapeau
jaune
j'ai choisi une question
allah
malmené par godard et doyon en parlant
takagi ah ouais ça je comprends manger
en plus figurativement manger chez ferré
torturé dans rana c'est pas un peu maso
dont le souhaitent des rouges
non c'est une esquisse des pas dit c'est
quand même parce que chaque fois qu'on
voit une fois été mangés tout cru dans
ce film que j'ai adoré yabon les blancs
dans la pirater des gamins füglister a
été décrété au mur on ne savait jamais
venu à l'esprit
qu'est ce que je pourrais dire de sens
et là dessus tu viens d'ailleurs jamais
dit avec jd oui mais est-ce que dans le
cid é tu prends des baffes
non mais non mais je vais pas vu comme
tout va bien quand même
personne ne s'intéresse sympa à regarder
des choses qui vont tous bien non
puisque malheureusement la seule façon
de produire quelque chose
malheureusement c'est après avoir
souffert ou bill bray non maintenant que
miss feutre on va passer la dernière
question une question rose tu me donnes
le chapeau rose
c'est gentil contrairement à ce que tout
le monde aurait compensé par les
difficultés liées aux départs condé
hollande quand il était jeune fille opel
s'est il arrivé d'avoir des aventures
avec les pères à non parce que nous
pensions non mais c'est comme ça non non
c'était pas ça je sais pas je n'aurai
pas garanti aurait pu se passer
mais j'étais arrivé de sa cible de
premier où il y avait que la mer avec
deux petites filles donc il n'y avait
pas de risque
ah bon pour été choisis les miss en paix
avec soi sinon je me dis pas un bon
choix zipang et bien j'en sais pas
regretter qu'il ait pas eu un bon
français et emprisonnant des lunettes en
écaille non non j'ai failli regretter
que j'avais pas la tête à ça et puis
j'ai vu très quand même
j'ai choisi est le père des enfants et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu